look here we're going to we're having
such a good time
but now you're going to have to answer
for sunny on the causeway okay
so um I'm just saying because stand up
you're one of 11 Senators who voted not
to certify the last election okay one of
11 do you think Biden didn't win look
Biden is clearly the president well
that's not the question or the
answer do you think he won was it a
election no those are very different
questions okay the did he win and is he
the president yes was it fair look there
were lots of things that were unfair
about the last ele but it's been combed
over more than any election ever even by
the people on your side and they say
it's not this is from your book you say
Democrats whose capacity for
shamelessness never ceases to Astound me
were no longer willing to play by the
rules of democracy now I know you're
funny now but is that a
joke the Democrats don't want to play by
the rules of democracy context before
and after that I'm sorry the one
sentence I'm not remembering well that I
know I don't know but you wrote that the
the Democrats are no longer willing to
play by the rules of democracy I wanted
to read it because I feel like it's the
exact opposite of what I think which is
that the Republicans including you
January 6 Etc are the ones who are no
longer willing to play by the rules of
democracy it seems like wait
wait it seems like your idea has
switched in the Republican party to
election only count if we win and then
we will endlessly litigate them even
though your own it was laugh at a court
like 60 different courts I mean all we
have the the secretaries of State even
the Republican ones everybody said
you're Trump's own election people said
it was the one of the most Fair well-run
elections ever why won't you let it go
so Bill you're the one that's not
letting it go you're the one that's
asking about it but but let me be clear
about something I'm asking about your
history listen I believe passionately in
democracy and and I also believe voter
fraud is a real and persistent problem
and it's weird that Democrats have taken
the view it's been study okay so you
don't think it is but you know what I
have never once seen you or or any other
host ask Hillary Clinton why she said in
2016 that Donald Trump was an
illegitimate president I've never seen
you ask Democrats why they objected to
the presidential certification in 2011
that was George W bush in 2005 that was
George W bush and in 2016 that was
Donald Trump and I don't think we should
be okay have a double standard here okay
well there is a double standard because
there's two different things going on
one is a remonstration a mild
protestation of something they did Al
Gore was the head of the Senate at the
time he had to pass the Baton an
election he knew he won and his he knew
he won election denier you just said Al
Gore won that election well he okay he
did not win he won I'm sorry you're
right you're right I I meant to say he
won the popular vote but but that's not
I understand I understand but but the
other candidate's brother stopped the
count okay that's that is that's not
accurate the Supreme Court stopped the
count his own brother ran that election
in Flor brother was the governor of
Florida you know they counted V hold on
hold on a second I mean facts matter
they counted the votes four times in
Florida George W bush won all four times
I was part of the legal team litigating
that case so I I was intimately involved
in Bush versus Gore every time they
counted the votes Bush won the bigger
point is that Al Gore took one for the
team he came out and said okay you know
this was a really up election but
this is America the jewel in our Crown
is that we pass power peacefully and I'm
not going to be the first guy not to do
that Nixon Let It Go in 1960 that could
have been a a screwy election and
Hillary came out in her goddamn purple
suit so she did it before the sun rose
she did it before the crowed three
times she came out and said Trump is the
president that's what you guys will not
do Joe Biden is the president what do
you mean we won't do it I'm fting him
every day and he's screwing up the
country in the world so I'm quite aware
Joe Biden's the president I wish he
wasn't but it's not lost on me who it is
that caused a war in Europe with Ukraine
that that that gave a hundred billion
dollars to Iran and the terrorists
attacking in Ukraine yes you want to
know how no but next time thank you I
got all right thank you that we're
spirited come back and see us I look
forward all right I'll see you on
overtime we can finish it up T
Cruz
that